I read your file
you're a very troubled young woman
believe it or not I'm here to help you
you know when you put your hand out of
the window of a moving car you can feel
the air and guide it I can push the air
together water to other stuff you
thought you out of some do I can teach
you this dude thank you for meeting with
us of course I understand you have some
concerns about your son Andy and I have
always been very close but we believe he
is being bullied and look who's here
so what's very good friend to my stupid
earth crazy
maybe they care about Andrew and Lauren
aware that there was a bit of an
incident at the school this evening I
need you to go get them for me they're
not going anywhere
we have to secure the safety the
community
sure about the nucleus
those are my catch you have to help them
why didn't you tell me you've power
dad put people like us in jail my
experience things change when it's your
own kid
[Music]
there is nothing more important to me
that my family the x-men the brother but
we don't even know if they exist anymore
I suggest you think about what's best
for your family
what do we do it's gonna be alright good
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a burden chest but sorry
tell me about Lorna the information I
have these yours
well names my family you say
[Music]
hey everybody awesome news there's a
brand new x-men TV show called the
gifted that's coming this fall on Fox
I'll explain how it's connected to the
movies Deadpool Logan's the timeline but
there are probably a couple big
characters that you spotted in the
trailer is because the Logan blu-ray
just dropped there's a new giveaway for
the blu-ray all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video but the gifted TV show is
going to be on Fox like you know Legion
is on FX it's by the same Marvel Fox
group so there is like a minor
connection in the comics between the
Legion character in what's going on with
this all explained because it's kind of
an easter egg but they haven't said how
directly connected all these x-men
universe shows are but the basic premise
is is you have a very great and creed
type of character working for like a
homeland security type organization we
don't know if it's going to be like
Trask industries because there are
sentinels in the series these are what
the Sentinels look like based on the
level of Technology you can kind of see
that this has happening closer to modern
day whereas Logan it's that way far in
the future currently that is the
furthest point in the x-men time light
right now between the movies and all the
TV shows they're living in a normal
neighborhood like a normal life but then
they find out their child has powers and
they become a target of the government
organization that they were working for
that's hunting down mutants like you see
here this one that he has trapped in a
ziplock bag so there are actually some
big x-men characters in the series you
probably spotted some of them already
just based on the way they use their
powers but the series is following their
family as they go on the run with their
children this is the son this is the
daughter but then because the father was
working for this auntie mutant
organization we also run afoul of a lot
of the people that he used to be hunting
down they mention a couple different
organizations inside the x-men universe
they go to this character here who's
eclipsed from the comics he's basically
like an alternate universe version of
sunspot he's the head of the mutant
resistance you see the big outbreak at
at school as he gets bullied he
manifests telekinetic powers actually a
couple of different powers because
there's some electromagnetism going on
here but his sister also displays
command of the elements she sort of like
their last airbender character so most
of these people are actual characters
from the comics I'll explain in a second
but that's who the family is there's
this big outbreaks
government comes calling for them the
people that he actually works for so you
see how it goes you have someone like a
William Stryker type character who's
forced to reevaluate the way he views
mutants and go on the roam with his
family so you have bad guy becoming good
guy you have to promise that my family
will be safe but you guys want to know
about the x-men characters in the
continuity and how this is connected to
x-men Legion so this is a really cool
stuff this is Polaris
she's Magneto's secret daughter you
never really learned who her mother is
but she basically has all the same
powers as Magneto it's just obviously
they're using the green color scheme
just like it is from the comics but like
I said this person is eclipse he's sort
of like an age of X universe version
like an alternate universe version of
sunspot Roberto DeCosta
but the sister here is Lauren Sherwood
she's called mantra from the comics she
basically just has control over the
element she can control earth wind fire
water you get it they mentioned the
x-men the Brotherhood of mutants in the
mutant resistance so this is sort of
like post x-men continuity but
relatively modern day just from the
characters that they're using it seems
like it's set in the Age of X universe
but they haven't confirmed any of those
details yet but the H of X universe was
actually like a fictional reality that
was created by the powers of the legion
character when someone else was trying
to make him sane and as a result of that
he actually creates this fictional
alternate reality called the age of X
reality and it was like this
post-apocalyptic x-men universe in the
comics where things are going way worse
for them you know you think of Age of
Apocalypse Age of X is sort of a riff on
that idea so if you saw the Logan movie
and you saw how like mutant said slowly
then hunted down and they had weeded
them out using a lot of passive genetics
like you put stuff in the food to
suppress the X gene in overtime you just
get rid of mutants because no new ones
are born imagine this is happening way
before that in the timeline but the
government Homeland Security are going
crazy
hunting mutants down because they're
afraid of them so things in the world
haven't gotten quite as bad as they are
during the Logan movie or say like Age
of Apocalypse but it's still really bad
and it's headed in that direction
I think this character here is warpath
James proud star but they haven't
confirmed that he's only listed as Sam
IMDb so they might confirm some of this
stuff later on but I think that's who
he's meant to be in the main character
Andy here I think is a version of alpha
from the comics who basically has like a
bunch of different powers that he can
only manifest one at a time but he just
like one of those Franklin Richards
type characters who's crazy powerful but
it looks like the only powers that he's
manifesting in the trailer are
telekinetic outbursts like he'd been
these here it's not like magnetism it's
more like telekinesis and then later in
the trailer here it's those sentinels
apart so he might manifest different
powers later that might be his only
power they've done the same thing with
the Legion TV show where like Legion has
a billion different powers in the comics
but this version of Legion we've only
seen use a couple of them so I just I
love the idea of them backdoor
connecting these TV shows because Legion
in the comics created the reality where
a lot of these people in the comics
exist so you're big comic book fan I
recommend you check out some of Age of X
it's not completely based on that it's
just they're borrowing a lot of elements
from that but this is just the first
trailer it's not going to drop to the
fall I don't think they've announced an
official premiere date yet but I will do
a new video when they release some more
footage they'll probably bring it to
Comic Con and do a big panel for it so
let me know in the comments what do you
guys think about this obviously the
x-men exist the Brotherhood mutants so
you have magneto Professor X if you were
wondering yet this is connected to the
x-men films so like anything that Fox is
doing from the Marvel Universe this is
connected to that like Patrick Stewart
said that he's probably going to get
star on Legion like he's really down for
that I don't know who's going to be
guest starring on this TV show there's
still a lot they haven't announced yet
so hopefully that answers some of those
questions but I think it's going to be
fun it's going to air on Fox not on FX
like the legion show but it's basically
the same people it's Marvel producing
with Fox people so new Marvel and DC
posting in a little while you can click
here to re-watch the trailer like this
is the Fox website where they're going
to be posting all their trailers for the
TV show and you can click here for brand
new guardians and infinity war thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight